these women can't do anything just
because they can doesn't mean they
should stand angels you have a new
client
who is she I can't sleep at night I'm
the lead programmer on a product that
can revolutionize the power industries
but there is a possibility it can be
weaponized and I'm 42 I'm Jane
who are you embossing
welcome to the pounds of agency we exist
because traditional law enforcement
can't keep up I don't like that boy you
guys are like lady spies Jane's former
mi6 Oh God
what did you to defend my compressed his
carotid and deoxygenated his brain stem
well that sounds painful don't worry
he's gonna wake up unless he doesn't
Sabina runs the ground game sano stuff
let's get the weapon before it becomes
every bad guy's favorite new toy take
her to the closet cheer her up we're
gonna need some wigs
we're still in the first pocket there's
another closet
just stop the touch some of these blows
up
[Music]
are you flirting with a handsome nerd
host not
[Music]
how'd that feel cuz it looks like it
felt really good how nice
[Music]
good morning angels morning charlie
[Music]